que lindo isso aqui e se eu pudesse para
você hoje
nesse exato momento o poder de ver o seu
futuro
será que vocês a alegria com o futuro
que você vai ver ou será que a partir
deste exato momento você mudaria tudo
para que o seu futuro seja completamente
diferente
o fato é que nessas seis nesse espaço de
terráqueos existem cerca de 8,7 milhões
de espécies de seres vivos diferentes
com tamanhos diferentes texturas
diferentes hábitats naturais diferentes
e com funções diferentes
as árvores nascem sabendo que vão
filtrar o ar dá frutos os peixes na da
usaa as aves voar encantarem e os gatos
bem os gatos para escravizar os seus
donos e fazer vídeos fofinhos pela
internet
dentre todas essas espécies a nossa o
homo sapiens mais conhecido como ser
humano que é o único que nasce com os
seguintes questionamentos o que eu sou o
que eu vim fazer aqui
qual a minha função nesse mundo e qual
será o meu futuro
e dentre 7,6 bilhões de seres humanos
que já se fizeram essa pergunta ou um
dia farão na assim o filho adora a minha
mãe me teve aos 17 anos e teve a minha
irmã aos 15 anos e teve que tomar uma
decisão muito cedo e muito importante
ela deixou me deixou com os meus avós
pra que eu e minha irmã tivéssemos um
futuro melhor
ela trabalhou para que eu começasse a
estudar muito cedo então comecei a
estudar os dois anos e aos seis anos de
idade eu já lia fluentemente e nessa
mesma idade uma professora da escolinha
chegou pra mim e perguntou jesus você
quer cantar na formatura da escola e eu
aceitei a gente ensaiou e quando vi
quando chegou o dia né
o dia em que o campeão já que bonitinho
e eu comecei todo tímido assim e logo
depois eu lembro público ea platéia
cantava junto comigo sorria junto comigo
e eu achei aquilo maravilhoso e pela
primeira vez eu pensei no meu futuro eu
pensei eu já sei o que você quando eu
crescer
eu serei cantor e os adultos acham
bonitinho mas no fundo torciam para que
o caso dela é bem rápido porque as
pessoas ser cantor trabalhar com arte
não é um bom futuro
mas eu não tava aí eu chegava em casa
pegava a colher de pau da minha avó ia
pro quintal e cantava para as árvores a
colher de pau era meu microfone e as
árvores dançavam ao som de jesus lucas
desde cedo
até que um dia brincando eu fui chamar
minha irmã na casa de um vizinho e eu
fui estuprado
eu sei que essa é uma informação tanto
assustadora pra muita gente mas é tão
assustadora quanto saber que 70 por
cento das vítimas de estupro no brasil
são crianças e adolescentes e um crime
como esse tende a ser silenciado
ninguém gosta de falar ninguém gosta de
ouvir e comigo não foi diferente
o medo se instalou e eu silenciei não
queria mais cantar
comecei a ter crises de pânico não
conseguia dormir e à minha família
movida por pela fé me levou o caminho da
espiritualidade e lá eu encontrei força
para enfrentar os medos os meus monstros
e um dia chegando à igreja eu vi um
grupo de dança e era como se uma
esperança rede ressurgisse em mim e eu
falei eu quero ser bailarina
eu chegava em casa ia para o quarto
escondidinho pegar a vassoura de palha
da minha avó e dançava com ela era minha
perfeita
a parceira meses depois o líder do grupo
de dança me chamou para participar lá
saiu sorridente
aprendi na dança que nem todo o toque é
malicioso nem todo o abraço é maldoso e
a dança me abrir o teatro no teatro eu
reaprende a falar em público e o teatro
o livro do teatro me deu um violão e eu
comecei a flertar novamente com o meu
primeiro sonho e eu comecei a aprender
violão sozinho em casa com revistinhas e
eu já tinha passado e superado tudo
aquilo
chegou o momento de eu cantar novamente
veio o show de calouros
então subi naquele palco com toda a
força do meu coração cantei como se não
houvesse amanhã
e quando eu desci uma senhora simpática
chegou até mim bateu os meus ombros e
disse meu filho o seu negócio a dançar
mesmo só que ela estava certa
eu tinha passado dez anos sem usar a
minha voz e avós como qualquer outro
instrumento se você não usa enferruje
espera
eu tinha aprendido a dançar eu tinha
aprendido a fazer teatro
eu posso aprender a cantar foi quando eu
descobri que no ensino médio tinha um
casal de voluntários que faziam aquilo
como e ajudavam outras crianças e
adolescentes a cantarem e eu fiz durante
três anos do três vezes por semana aulas
de canto e finalmente estava cantando lá
saiu cantando sozinho e então eu falei
você cantou sei cantar só que chegou o
momento de escolher o futuro e nesse
momento eu precisava dar de volta tudo
aquilo que a minha mãe e minha avó
investir em mim eu queria ajudar
financeiramente eu não tinha passado no
curso que eu queria que era design e eu
não tinha o emprego então comecei a
distribuir largar essa idéia de ser
cantor como
distribuir currículos até que um dia uma
empresa me chamou para fazer uma
entrevista só que a mulher que foi
entrevistar não foi dizer eu não fui
entrevistar eu fiquei das 8 às 12 e
esperando e aí voltei de lá frustrado e
decide ligar para uma antiga paixão do
coral e quem atendeu foi a mãe dela a
dona rosa ea dona rosa
sabendo da situação falou meu filho veio
para joinville que aqui você vai
conseguir emprego você vai logo está
estudando e não pensei duas vezes fiz
uma rifa e com uma mala de roupas e
duzentos reais no bolso eu vim pra
joinville
fui viver o meu futuro e quando eu
cheguei a joinville eu trabalhei como
empurrador de carrinho de supermercado
se afinal de contas os carrinhos
supermercados não volto sozinho do
estacionamento estava em várias coisas
até que eu consegui o emprego dos meus
sonhos
uma startup que me permitia ter horário
flexível comida bebida e tocar violão e
quando eu tocava violão acontecia isso
as pessoas se conectavam algumas se
conectava o ponto de topo de contar
coisas particulares da sua vida e me
incentivaram a colocar isso para mais
pessoas ouvir e eu fiz um canal no
youtube e mais a conexões acontecerão
até que um dia uma menina chegou pra mim
e falou jesus lucas eu tenho depressão e
quando eu escuto as suas canções
eu tenho vontade de viver nenhum emprego
nenhum salário me trouxe tanta
satisfação quando saber disso ela também
contou que ela tinha sido abusadas na
infância e pela primeira vez eu pude me
sentir confiante de compartilhar com
alguém algo que aconteceu no meu passado
eu tenho contado à força são as conexões
era olhar nos olhos que eu vi lá quando
eu era criança era isso que me conectava
então eu fui para são paulo tentar um
reality show fiquei lá passei a primeira
fase
não passei a segunda voltei pra
joinville quando voltei pra joinville
fui chamado do que nessa linha e vocês
sabem o que acontece quando você chega
nessa linha do seu emprego
eu fui demitido mas
fiquei feliz porque agora eu tinha
forças
qualquer a força à força como histórias
do thalisson que disse que largou
medicina para fazer teatro depois de
ouvir uma música minha ou do rafael que
sofria de insônia mas ouve as minhas
músicas e conseguia dormir
tranquilamente ou da dani que estava
sete anos no relacionamento no
relacionamento onde era infeliz e depois
de ouvir uma música minha ela decidiu se
livrar do cafajeste e eu falei você
cantor é isso que você agora vai
e aí eu comecei a cantar em tudo quanto
é evento da cidade que eu tinha de cunho
social
de repente um tal de jesus lucas era
onipresente de verdade estava em tudo
quanto é canto até que chegou o dia que
uma que uma uma empresa uma um evento me
convidou para fazer o meu próprio show e
o que aconteceu isso aqui as pessoas que
me conheceram na internet me conheceram
nos eventos foram pro meu primeiro show
e ali o meu futuro começou a virar
notícia juntar diálogo surgiu e depois
então eu começo todo seu trabalho todos
os dias para que eu possa me conectar
com mais pessoas porque eu acredito que
o amor quando a gente faz alguma coisa
com amor
isso muda não apenas a nossa vida mas
como a muda a vida de outras pessoas
como o amor da minha mãe como amor da
minha professora como amor de cada
pessoa que passou pela minha vida o que
elas faziam com amor
mudou a minha trajetória de vida e eu
posso fazer isso também através das
minhas canções
foi quando eu me perguntei tá eo meu
futuro
o meu futuro gente é igual ao de vocês a
gente nasce cresce
alguns se reproduz em outros não e
depois a gente morre é o seu fato o que
fica é uma história que a gente deixa e
é por isso que eu canto eu canto pra que
a gente possa perceber que nós temos
tamanhos diferentes cores diferentes
religiões crenças diferentes
sexualidades diferentes
e funções diferentes
mas nós temos uma só bandeira você
conhece essa bandeira é a bandeira do
planeta terra
o lugar onde eu e você temos todos os
recursos para viver os nossos sonhos e
para construir a nossa história o lugar
onde eu e você vivemos todos os dias
essa bandeira é de todos nós e é por
isso que eu canto eu sou jesus lucas eu
sou cantor
eu sou apenas um ser humano que ama
cantar ama fazer o que faz a minha mãe
me ensinou que cada pessoa é importante
ela me ensinou que cada um de nós temos
uma função que é importante porque um
quebra cabeça não é completo se faltar
uma peça todos nós somos importantes e
esse evento só acontece porque tem um
monte de gente trabalhando por trás e eu
quero agradecer por essa oportunidade de
hoje poder compartilhar com todos vocês
que estão trabalhando nesse evento e que
estão nesse evento que vale a pena lutar
para que os nossos filhos tenham um
futuro melhor do que o nosso e é com
essa frase que eu quero entregar uma
canção que eu fiz pensando nisso eu vou
cantar para vocês
[Aplausos]
[Música]
preste atenção à vida está passando bem
na sua frente que você não fica tudo
tudo está diferente em transam em
trânsito em mutação nada é estático de
onde vem tudo o que eu vejo qualquer
feito de gente do que 70 em porque
chamei já é tão indiferente no entanto
incerto não tem paixão não tem ao teto
mas olha dentro do seu coração mandou
linha só não faz verão que eu não sonho
do meu pai nosso e eu lá sem humanidade
muito ythaca a viel eu to eye to eye e
eu em ok ei lá sem humanidade muito está
tratado muito motor e aumentou sua vai
radiografar foi na rua mas tentou a
humanidade eu me pergunto por que
aconteceu desabafa anos nós destruímos o
eu tivemos a idéia de que tudo é
individual não temos até prisão tapado
disse klaus que você não entende é que
tá errado uma visão mais fracas em preto
batata enquanto lá alguém chantôme celpe
luiz gandini
em voltar pra quê
em um giro de winton amanhã pode ser
você e eu eu cair em gostei e eu não
ganhei em nota que eu ganhei em alguém
[Aplausos]
tem uma unidade muito ythaca ave é eu
sei você não tem ninguém é
el eu sei você não fui nem ninguém
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a esperança novos a nó
a esperança nós esteróis a el salvador
[Aplausos]
edinho é não cair e eu nunca ninguém em
nosso oi e eu não sonho ei alguém flua
sem humanidade não cuida acabado dessa
intenção
a vida está passando bem na sua frente
[Aplausos]